en el vídeo pasado analizamos el precio
de un galón de gasolina y vimos cómo de
ese dinero cuánto se quedaba cada quien
es decir analizamos cuánto se quedaba en
la gasolinera cuánto se quedaba en el
transporte cuánto se quedaban la
refinería cuánto en impuestos en el pozo
petrolero y hasta las tarjetas de
crédito metimos y bueno todos estos
precios cambian según en donde estemos
en el mundo y en qué mercado tengamos y
también cambiando estos porcentajes
dependiendo del lugar en el que te
encuentres por ejemplo el porcentaje que
se lleva a la gasolinera hay veces que
sube hasta 30 centavos o los impuestos
pueden ser mucho más altos o más
pequeños o tal vez en su dado caso la
refinería no venda las otras cosas no
estén aptas para venderse o no se vendan
en ese país y entonces cobrará mucho más
por la gasolina o inclusive el barril
del petróleo puede ser más caro ahora en
este vídeo mi pregunta va a ser esta los
jugadores en esta oferta de gasolina
tienen sus ganancias como una función
del precio del petróleo es decir los
productores del petróleo y es que hay
que ser claros con esto muchas veces
esta producción
solamente de una misma compañía a esto
se le conoce como productores integrados
verticalmente de petróleo pero podemos
enfocarnos en que muchas veces hay
diferentes jugadores y cuando los hay es
claro que entonces se tiene que
regularizar un precio porque todos los
productores al final gastan un cuenta
dinero al buscar el petróleo y explorar
la tierra y el mar y después extraerlo y
es justo por esto si a ellos les cuesta
mucho trabajo extraer el petróleo que
cuesta más un barril de petróleo por
ejemplo si se gastan 1 ó 2 millones de
dólares en la extracción de stem tal vez
sería factible vender el petróleo a 30
dólares por barril ahora obviamente si
el barril de petróleo cuesta 100 dólares
los productores estarían haciendo 70
dólares de ganancia mientras que por
otro lado si el barril de petróleo cae
15 dólares estarían muertos pues las
pérdidas serían muy grandes y es justo
por esta razón que regularizar el precio
del petróleo no es nada sencillo porque
al final los productores pueden poner un
cierto precio y con este precio obtener
una ganancia descomunal o en su lado
caso con este mismo precio
pérdidas irreparables y eso también
depende bastante de cómo se cotice el
petróleo en una bolsa de valores y
además en cómo está funcionando este
mismo país por lo tanto vamos a verlo en
esta siguiente pregunta y esta pregunta
que quiero hacerles en estos momentos no
es una pregunta simple hay personas que
han gastado toda su vida o su carrera en
intentar estudiar la responderla y la
pregunta es cómo se dicta el precio
actual del petróleo y una pequeña parte
de la respuesta es que las curvas de la
demanda y la oferta se comportan igual
que cualquier otras si lo vemos a largo
plazo
sin embargo fíjate aquí en el 2008 el
precio del barril subió hasta 150
dólares viendo unos meses más tardes
cayó hasta 32 dólares por barril cayó
con un factor de un quinto y bueno aquí
hubo algo que pasó que fue la crisis
financiera y entonces las expectaciones
globales de cayeron la gente utilizaba
menos esta fuente de energía menos
provisiones etcétera pero esto no haría
que creciera si el precio del petróleo
algo más tuvo que haber pasado puede ser
que las personas vieron que el precio
empezó a subir y después
ellos mismos lo manejaron hasta el pique
y es que al final los mismos
consumidores también manejan el precio
del petróleo si lo compran más si lo
consumen más o si no lo consumen tanto y
para que entendamos un poco mejor todo
esto y ponerlo más en concreto si
pensamos en el precio o en su dado caso
pensamos más particularmente en el
mercado del petróleo tanto a largo como
a corto plazo y para hacerlo más
concreto de una vez empecemos con los
términos a largo plazo primero déjenme
hacer la siguiente gráfica por aquí no
podemos pensar el mercado del petróleo
como cualquier mercado tradicional
microeconómico y es que el petróleo es
un caso curioso porque micro
económicamente hablando es un gran
servicio que tiene grandes implicaciones
en la macroeconomía de un país de una
nación o en como ellos actúan pensemos
en largo plazo tenemos el precio contra
la cantidad y bueno para pequeñas
cantidades de barriles es económico
producirlos y después para cada
incremento de miles de barriles ojo la
cantidad está pensada en miles de
barriles por día para que obtengamos más
barriles se necesita
flor armas lugares y más tecnología y
por lo tanto el costo aumenta el costo
marginal y así creamos la curva de la
oferta y otra forma de pensarlo podría
ser que a precios bajos de producción
podría decir hey cuánto petróleo tenemos
cuánto hemos producido y verás que es
poco y viceversa la curva de la oferta
una curva de la oferta clásica por lo
tanto esta es la de la oferta y si ahora
pensamos en la demanda la podemos ver de
manera clásica si son pocos barriles de
petróleo el precio va a ser alto y esto
para obtener un gran beneficio pues
imagínate la importancia de obtener
petróleo para el consumidor es una
fuente de energía para muchos
consumidores y para otros es su única
fuente de energía y eso hace un gran
beneficio sin embargo este beneficio en
el precio va a disminuir entre más
aumente la cantidad de barriles otra
forma de verlo es a precios altos hay
mucha gente interesada en ello y por eso
habrá muchas otras formas de buscar
energía y a precios bajos la gente va a
optar por comprar mucho petróleo todo el
petróleo que puedan usar voy a usar mi
auto hasta para ir a la tienda de la
esquina
pues la gasolina es barata etcétera y
con esto construimos la curva de la
demanda y además la otra forma clásica
del modelo hablando a largo plazo es por
supuesto que tenemos un punto de
equilibrio con sus respectivos precio y
cantidad de equilibrio pero bueno este
modelo a largo plazo no describe nada
bien que es lo que está pasando aquí
arriba porque entre estos dos valores
tenemos un cambio dramático que al final
cuando el petróleo oferta en el mercado
no tiene cambios tan bruscos ni describe
el comportamiento de las personas de
consumir o no consumir mucho petróleo me
encantan una forma de pensarlo es que
esta gráfica es a largo plazo y podemos
pensar en la dinámica sobre esta curva
supongamos que se descubre una nueva
tecnología para sacar más petróleo eso
haría que la oferta aumente y la curva
de la oferta se desplace a la derecha o
por otra parte no sé la gente empieza a
usar más automóviles eléctricos lo que
hace que la demanda disminuya y por lo
tanto la curva de la demanda se desplace
hacia la izquierda o por último ejemplo
si de repente de nuevo se vuelve popular
el uso del automóvil de gasolina la
curva se expresaría hacia la derecha
y es que piénsalo si hay más
perforaciones y se obtiene más
yo la curva de la oferta se mueve la
derecha si decrece la producción de
petróleo la curva se movería a la
izquierda y así hay más ejemplos y
además puedes figurar las implicaciones
de esto es decir la relación del precio
del petróleo a largo plazo con cualquier
otra cosa que pueda pasar pero es hora
de pensar un poco en qué es lo que va a
pasar a corto plazo y cuando digo a
corto plazo no me refiero a segundo a
segundo me refiero más a un periodo de
mes a mes o tal vez a un periodo de
pocos años y es que esto es porque el
comportamiento de la gente puede cambiar
dramáticamente de un momento a otro se
pueden comprar más autos o usar menos el
automóvil y no consumir tanto y es por
eso que predecir a corto plazo no es
nada fácil humano por lo tanto el modelo
a corto plazo se va a ver más o menos
así claro con varias simplificaciones
pero no cambia mucho este gráfico sin
embargo esta es sólo una estimación
precio contra cantidad así que a corto
plazo la cantidad de oferta no
forzosamente va a ser sensible al precio
por lo tanto se ve así como una línea
vertical y es que en un par de meses la
gente puede ser que use menos gasolina o
que bombeen menos
de la que se había estimado por lo tanto
esto se ve reflejado en el mercado y
esta es la curva de la oferta sin tener
en cuenta el precio recuerda que a largo
plazo la cantidad aumenta el precio
aumenta si la cantidad disminuye el
precio disminuye pero todo esto lleva a
un cierto tiempo y además si empezamos
desde la perspectiva de la exploración
la curva de la oferta no va a ser
sensible al precio y la demanda se va a
ver algo así de nuevo les digo que es un
modelo simple y no lo tomen como dogma
de fe la demanda se va a ver más o menos
así recuerda con una línea vertical
porque estamos diciendo que la cantidad
no se ve afectada por el precio y bueno
ahora pensemos en la demanda la curva de
la demanda va a ser esta que voy a
dibujar de color naranja va a ser algo
así una curva un poco extraña y la razón
de por qué se ve así es porque el
comportamiento de la gente puede cambiar
repentinamente vamos a fijarnos en el
precio de equilibrio que está justo por
aquí y después lo aumentamos hasta por
acá realmente el comportamiento de la
gente no va a cambiar dramáticamente la
distancia del trabajo a la casa sigue
siendo la misma
sería mucho más difícil pensar en
mudarse más cerca del trabajo o de la
escuela o conseguir un nuevo trabajo o
vender el automóvil para comprar un
cierto automóvil eléctrico o un
automóvil solar y todo esto si sube un
poco el precio de la gasolina y de igual
manera es el precio baja un poco así que
a corto plazo esta gráfica se va a
adaptar a las micro económicas entradas
y microeconómicos factores en términos
de la demanda y la oferta pero bueno
ahora si llegamos a la raíz de todo esto
y la raíz es la psicología del mercado y
es que todo esto suele afectar la
psicología del mercado como en esta foto
que tenemos aquí todas estas personas
que tenemos aquí están en la bolsa del
mercado de chicago que es justo donde se
negocian contratos futuros y tal vez en
vídeos posteriores podemos hablar un
poco acerca de contratos futuros ya qué
me refiero con ello y es que mira en
lugar de tener a miles de personas con
barriles de petróleos cargando los para
venderlos lo mejor es decir que voy a
conseguir tantos barriles de petróleo
para un día específico y la gente
negocia con ello pero bueno regresando a
corto plazo lo que realmente maneja el
precio del gas
lo que realmente causa estas
fluctuaciones de aquí cosa que no puede
ser descrita por todas estas gráficas
que tenemos aquí es la psicología de la
gente y también la información que
obtienen las personas y es que en
situaciones como la del medio este se
dice por ejemplo benjamín netanyahu el
primer ministro de israel decidiera
bombardear a irán
aparentemente aquí está el presidente de
iran y todo esto en un atentado para
deshacerse de su programa nuclear porque
irán está haciendo cosas atroces y
realmente aunque hay muchos que no lo
creen existe gente que sí lo cree y
entonces ellos los que se creen atrás en
los siguientes contratos futuros o
compran esos contratos futuros
intentando vender los más caros en un
futuro y entonces toda la gente creyendo
que el petróleo le va a costar mucho más
caro entonces no va a decidir venderlo y
mejor va a decidir guardarlo ellos van a
pensar que el petróleo estará escaso en
algún punto próximo en el futuro así que
lo que quiero que veas es cómo estas
cosas es decir la producción de gasolina
las otras fuentes de energía el
comportamiento de la gente hacen que
cambie el aspecto
plazo pero si hablamos de a corto plazo
es la psicología del mercado la que
causa estas estrepitosas caídas en el
precio del petróleo